AND NO ECONOMIC INTERVENTION AS
A SPUR TO THE FOLKS ON THE
HILTON OUTLET IT GET OUT OF
PLACE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US ALL THE
INS AND OUTS.
THE BATTLE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS
WITH IMMEDIATE NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON BUSINESSES FROM WALL STREET
TO MAIN STREET AND EVERYWHERE IN
BETWEEN.
SO THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
WORKING FEVERISHLY WITH THE
SENATE THIS WEEK TO TRY TO GET
RELIEF TO AMERICANS WHO NEED IT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> THEY CAN DEFINITELY AFFORD IT
IT.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES AND ALL OF THESE
COMPANIES, FURLOUGH, WHAT IS THE
MESSAGE TO THEM?
>> President Trump: THIS IS
NOBODY’S FAULT.
IT HAPPENED AND WE WILL TAKE
CARE OF CARE OF IT.
>> Shannon: THE PARTNER OF THE
HILL RESTAURANT GROUP IS ALREADY
EXPERIENCING THIS REALITY.
HE JOINS US LIVE.
TOM, GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
I KNOW BECAUSE I READ ABOUT YOUR
STORY THAT YOU EMPLOY A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU CARE ABOUT AND
INDIVIDUALLY KNOW ABOUT THEM BUT
THE POLICY NOW IN D.C. THAT HAS
BEEN ROLLED OUT MEANS REAL
TROUBLE FOR YOU.
TELL US YOUR SITUATION.
>> WELL, LISTEN, IT HAS BEEN
VERY TOUGH.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, OVERNIGHT, WE
GET TOLD WE PRETTY MUCH HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN.
THE FIRST ROLLOUT WAS THAT WE
HAD TO LIMIT SEATING WHICH WOULD
PRETTY MUCH PUT US OUT OF
BUSINESS.
AND WITH THE NEW SHUT DOWN
PRETTY MUCH, 150 EMPLOYEES THAT
I’D PRETTY MUCH HAD TO FURLOUGH
IMMEDIATELY.
YOU KNOW, WE JUST COME OUT OF A
SLOW SEASON IN D.C.
SO IT’S NOT LIKE WE ARE FLUSH
WITH CASH COMING INTO THE
SEASON.
WE USUALLY MAKE OUR MONEY.
>> Shannon: THIS IS THE TIME
OF YEAR FOR FOLKS WHO DON’T
KNOW, CHERRY BLOSSOMS BLOOM AND
WE GET A TON OF TOURISM THAT
POURS IN THIS TIME OF YEAR AND
LIGHTS UP THE RESTAURANTS,
THEATERS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
ARE YOU ABLE TO DO ANYTHING WITH
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE DELIVERY
OR CARRY OUT?
I KNOW A LOT OF RESTAURANTS ARE
TRYING TO DO THAT TO STRING
TOGETHER SOME WORK.
IS THAT A POSSIBILITY FOR YOU?
>> MOST OF OURS ARE NOT SET UP
FOR THAT.
WE ARE MORE DYNAMIC AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PROCEED RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW WITH D.C. GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW, I THINK THEY PASS
SOMETHING LATE THIS EVENING.
I HAVEN’T GOT TO READ UP ON IT
YET, BUT DEFINITELY SUPPORTING
THE WORKFORCE.
OUR BIG CONCERN BUT THIS WHOLE
SHUTDOWN WAS OUR EMPLOYEES.
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO HANG ONTO
THEM AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
I ACTUALLY GOT A LITTLE TIFF
WITH THE MAYOR.
>> Shannon: WHEN SHE WAS
INITIALLY ROLLING THINGS OUT,
NO, YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES TO PAY
AND THEY HAVE FAMILIES TO FEED.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
STAY OPEN.
SHE BASICALLY SAID, I’M NOT
GIVING YOU AN OPTION.
THIS IS A POLICY, AND YOU’VE GOT
TO DO IT.
>> WHEN SHE FIRST ROLLED OUT THE
FIRST PROPOSAL, LIMITING 6 FEET
APART AND NO BAR SEATING, THAT
WASN’T FAIR.
THE BIG PLACES CAN HANDLE THAT.
TWO OR 300 SEATS, THE SMALL
BUSINESSES, I WOULD HAVE TO SHUT
HALF OF MY BUSINESSES DOWN.
I COULDN’T COMPLY.
SO I ACTUALLY PUT OUT A POST,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, PROBABLY DID
HAVE A LITTLE HASTILY AND PICKED
A FIGHT WITH THE MAYOR.
I TOLD PRETTY MUCH I WAS NOT
GOING TO COMPLY.
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY, IT EVEN
HAD A TALK WITH THE OFFICE AND
IF YOU ARE GOING TO DO IT, YOU
NEED TO SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN.
THE NEXT THING, SHE DID TO.
SO WE NEVER NOT COMPLIED.
>> Shannon: NO, I MEAN,
LISTEN, YOU HAVE SO MANY THAT
DEPEND ON YOU.
WE ARE ALL A LITTLE EMOTIONAL AS
THIS THING ROLLS OUT AND TRY TO
KEEP THINGS TOGETHER.
ONE OF THE OTHER BUSINESSES AND
SEVERAL HAVE BEEN QUOTED IN D.C.
AS HAPPENING ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY NOW.
IN D.C., THE TALK ABOUT THIS.
THE HOMETOWN ROASTER COFFEE LAID
OFF 150 OF 189 EMPLOYEES.
80% OF ITS STAFF ACCORDING TO AN
EMAIL FROM THE COFOUNDERS, THEY
SHOWED THE LEAST DAMAGING OF
THEIR BAD OPTIONS.
OPTING TO LAY OFF TO APPLY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
THESE HAVE TO BE INCREDIBLY
PAINFUL DECISIONS FOR YOU TO
MAKE.
PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEM, YOU
KNOW, EVERY MINUTE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
WHAT IS THAT LIKE?
>> THE HARDEST PART IS THE
INDECISION.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW LONG IT WILL
IN FACT OR HOW LONG IT WILL BE.
WHAT DO YOU TELL YOUR EMPLOYEES?
WHEN DID WE GET TO COME BACK TO
WORK WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE
ASKING, TWO WEEKS, TWO MONTHS,
WHO KNOWS?
IT WAS A TOUGH DECISION AND
PRETTY MUCH WE SHUT EVERYTHING
DOWN SO WE ARE IN DAMAGE CONTROL
MODE RIGHT NOW.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THERE WILL BE
SUPPORT OR HELP FROM GOVERNMENT.
WE DON’T KNOW -- IT IS FINE IF
THEY WANT TO GIVE US SBA LOANS
BUT WE ARE JUST BORROWING MONEY.
WE HAVE TO PAY THAT BACK.
IF WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE OPEN
FOR DAYS, MONTHS, WE DON’T KNOW
WHERE WE WILL BE.
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE ARE DOING AND
HOW WE ARE GOING TO DO IT.
IT IS A VERY TOUGH SITUATION.
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY IS IN IT.
ALL OF THE RESTAURANTS ARE SHUT
DOWN.
IT’S NOT JUST US.
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO THE SAME
THING.
I TALKED TO MULTIPLE RESTAURANT
OWNERS IN D.C., AND THEY ARE ALL
GOING THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS.
>> Shannon: YEAH, AND SO WHEN
YOU ARE THE REAL LIFE FACE AND
YOUR EMPLOYERS ARE THE THE REAL
FACES IN THE STORIES WE HEAR
ABOUT BEING FINANCIALLY
IMPACTED, WE WISH YOU THE BEST.